This app is basically designed to make getting great food, great grub...
...finding restaurants, pubs, and markets really easy around Great Britain.
So, I've kicked it off by putting all of my recommendations across Britain on this app.
Also, all of my foodie mates and friends have done exactly the same,...
...and then all my chefs from over 25 cities in Britain have done all of their personal favorites.
As well, we're working with the Rough Guides,...
....so we've got over a thousand recommendations that I'm really pleased with.
We've got places where you can eat, places where you can visit,...
...and places where you can buy incredible food.
What's really cool about this app is if there's a place that you love...
...and you can do something really special,...
...you can share with us with just a couple of clicks, I'll be doing the same...
...and it means that this app is gonna continue to evolve and grow and get bigger and better.